mobile bonsoir donc vous resterez romain
goupil dans la légende comme l'un des
plus jeunes acteurs de 68
mais vous étiez politisé bien avant 68
puisque vous avez participé à la
création des comités vietnam lycéens des
comités d'action lycéenne et après 68
quand beaucoup pensent que la bagarre a
été perdu vous pensez avoir gagné parce
que vous dites on a débloqué la société
la télévision était décoincer il ya eu
les chartered le rock'n'roll les joints
à la libération sexuelle etc et ensuite
j'avais fait du cinéma mais sans jamais
renier vos idées vous n'êtes pas pour
reprendre un terme qu'emploient qu'il
sent combas vous n'êtes pas devenu
marchand voilà alors aujourd'hui j'ai
voulu vous soyez là parce que vous êtes
je dirais l'incarnation d'un soixante
huitard 10 mhz qui s'est pas à baisser
dans le commerce et dans le dans les
places dans les honneurs il est resté
très intègre et c'est pour ça que je
vous ai demandé de réunir une sorte de
vestale quoi voilà exactement
vous êtes né cela nous met elle à 2 61
68 ans alors vous pensez quoi du bouquin
de combat ça vous ça vous est riche il
un peu raison quand même non non pas du
tout au rien en rien c'est une
abomination
sur le fond sur la forme
c'est particulièrement insupportable
toutes les citations que je peux faire
sexiste raciste il se trouve que je les
lui ouais j'ai fait une grosse connerie
j'aurais dû me contenter de lire le
titre wpt est de savoir en creuse que ça
veut dire enfants sans foi ni loi
ce qu'ils regrettent tout son livre ses
quais pas deux fois ils l'expliquent la
foi catholique chrétienne l'europe que
quand une licence et je vais je sais pas
c'est dedans - du beau et dans le
quatrième de couverture
j'aurais pu me contenter de lire ça et
bien c'est à 10 ans j'ai connu un monde
où l'on craignait ses parents où on le
recherchait approbation de ses
professeurs c'est à dire la crainte
l'obéissance effectivement à dix ans
après à 20 ans j'ai subi la bohème de la
pensée il a subi il a été responsable de
rien à aucun moment dont il hérite rhin
à 10 ans il subit à 20 ans à 40 ans j'ai
vu la violence développer il fait rien
contre l'un est maintenant à 60 ans
faute d'avoir pu leur inculquer les
règles
ces règles à lui sa vérité ces
saloperies contre les frais quand les
connais je vais les règles qui sont ici
avancé comme un programme dit c'est le
front national direct avec une haine
absolue vous l'avez entendu dans
l'intervention contre le sida ce à dire
qu'en plus il détient il sait quelle est
la vérité
et quand il parle des hordes sans arrêt
il y parle d or des enfants lui
oui ben tu as tu as lu quoi tu as lu en
creux ou même directement que céléber
que c'est les musulmans que c'est
l'immigration c'est eux qui vont
déferler
c'est eux qui change la mentalité c'est
eux qui empêche ce rêve absolu
nostalgiques de quelle période
de quelle période vous me parlez de
quelle période bon jeu d'avant 68
si vous avez décidé vous avez décidé de
paiement message
question n'a rien décidé de vous lire
romain goupil vous êtes je pense est
d'accord mais ce que je lui réponds
clarations d'attention personnel et
surtout il invente le contrat de me
regarder il est allé chez denis gargaud
n'était pas témoin il invente le contenu
du livre qui doivent gagner je viens de
jeu c'est à dire par exemple qui dit que
je suis pour le retour à un ordre
catholique et céline avantagerait série
vous êtes quand même solide mais non il
n'y a aucun désir de retour dans l'ordre
car ce linéaire de retour à l'ordre
général et je lis ça tellement l'objet
du livre c'est à dire c'est de dire
attention vous n'avez pas voulu imposer
à ses enfants un ordre minimum il vous
imposeront un ordre maximum c'est tout
je n'ai rien dit je ne dis rien d'autre
tout le reste c'est de la littérature et
je pense être plus doués pour ça que lui
mais apparemment c'est qu'il est plus
littéraire que moi ils fabriquent ils
fabriquent une histoire autour de mon
livre est un procédé que je ne me pense
qu'on défend non ma cité alors si tu es
moi l'endroit où je dis qu'il faut
revenir à la france catholique sam a eu
tout à tout à fait alors c'est à dire
qu'on va pas au code
on y va elle a l'on dit sur le
fonctionnement patch épices et toutes
les pages tous les vaches et les
cochonneries donc prison sur pièce sur
pièce ça c'est page 13
ça démarre mal au moment où les portes
du wagon vont se fermer quatre juges
quatre jeunes gens montent la cigarette
au bec
il n'est plus permis de décrire ce genre
d'oiseau sans s'exposer aux rigueurs de
leur ligne de protection
je laisse donc à chacun le soin de les
imaginer alors non mais quand vous
faites ce système là en creux ça veut
dire quoi c'est genre d'oiseau la mairie
de protection c'est la licra temps s'est
attelée l'icsi janati s'est rendu jeudi
dans les deux cités je dis qu'il ya eu
agression et je ne dis je vous écris pas
les agresseurs vous laisse imaginer
comme vous voulez mais ce qu'on peut
être plus honnête que ça en plus des 15
votre matériel ce qui se passe quand ton
cas
ces téléviseurs ont même suivi c'est
quoi ces 1 800 vient là en l'occurrence
page 13 je me dis attention en écrivant
ce livre je me dis attention tu vas
quand même pas de offrir le prêter le
flanc à la critique
tu vas tu vas pas à les décrire ses
adversaires il a eu agression je raconte
une agression aller real elle m'a été
racontée par l'agresser je ne décris pas
les agresseurs et me reproche de ne pas
le faire on rêve dans l'eure dans les
termes dans les termes où ces dix ans
vous voyez vous imaginez tout ce que je
veux dire
et bien national fondation suisse romain
comme un pardon ascenseur pour les
fachos est un mauvais jeu de mots par
rapport à un film de truffaut et après
tout le bouquin tout le bouquin et
qu'une série d'allusions haineuse contre
les films mais demande en quoi vous
habite alors un exemplaire sur les jeux
vidéo
il demande effectivement la censure et
l'interdiction mais après tout les
titres sont cités fest'n alors là le le
passage j'ai pas le temps une horreur
après la fureur de vivre jusqu'à face
tueurs nés m'attriste crime c'est que
des attaques mais lisons un paillage
lequel de la façon que gm qui se
développe contre le sida n'est en rien
les plans les journaux ce crime n'y
aurait pas journaux le lien avec le
crime était connue puisque les deux ou
trois jeunes gens qui ont tué leurs
parents ou leur beau père étaient
déguisés en personnages du film le lien
est immédiat évident dire le contraire
chez mendon voilà ce que vous exposez
exactement ce qui l'exposé dit les films
et les bêtes en scène ce qui disait tout
à l'heure sur le téléfilm devrait être
édifiant mais en soirée mais les médias
de l'ordre vais vous dire il vous envoie
m danone entre autres un film dont on
s'inspire pour poignarder son entourage
vient film édifiant il ya toute une
marche et ça s'appelle de cinéma et sur
les valseuses les jeux wii alors ça les
valseuses on peut en parlant je vous dit
que les 26 juillet puis scandale pour
moi c'était devenu un film culte
oui c'est moi c'est pas un film culte
c'est une invitation à la barbarie et je
fais partie de ceux qui trouvent les
valseuses dégueulasse mais attention je
n'ai pas dit que gestion si ça va
jusqu'au 22 mai cette ville ne manquez
pas le droit d'avoir des arguments
inverses à ceux jugés difficiles vite le
puy 12 15 20 ans les gens qui pensent
que les valseuses sont un film
dégueulasse qui n'a pas être présenté à
tf1 à 20h30 n'ont pas la parole si vous
l'avez vous me la donnez
si ces travaux annoncés le service
public c'est fun c'est tout le monde en
parle maintenant le droit de s'exprimer
c'est bien voilà après pas je cite les
pages ça quand ça qui est tombé cela dit
je voudrais même pas cité les patchs à
serrières vient d'acheter ce livre on a
rien à [ __ ] c'est l'avenir continue à
suivre
c'est de l'anti
anti anti promotion vous remercier assez
marrant comme les gens sont un peu plus
de jugement que vous avez l'air de le
supposer
oliver stone et est traité de deux fous
parano on va en parler vous voulez on
part en part l'instant il ya un film qui
fit qui fuit et qui est vraiment culte
scarface tony montana et tout le monde
le sait la banlieue qui nous écoutent le
sait aussi et est éteint un héros dans
la banlieue ce film puisque un fait
c'est quand même un film c'est comme un
film on découpe à l'homme tous vivent à
coups de tronçonneuse
je vous demande de vous arrêter sur
simplement un seul truc et après
effectivement tout ça on perd un tout
petit peu de temps page 30
cette sollicitation jamais je suis prêt
à marjah l'un des traits à bat pas avec
lui tu verrais les laisse aux femmes et
aux quais homosexuels dans le bouquin
mais c'est une heure pour l'emmerder 1
pour le bien de la des traits les plus
criants de la dérive vers le sud avec le
mans
l'un des traits les plus criants de la
dérive vers le soupçon généralisé et
l'apparation l'apparition d'une
génération de femmes juges et de femmes
politiques à la vertu impitoyable elle
illustre d'abord est trop fréquemment le
besoin qu'ont éprouvé certaines filles
de famille éduquée d'en remontrer à leur
père il s'agit pour nombre d'entre elles
d'être honorée à leur tour pour leur
intransigeance est en mesure à leur tour
de faire la loi
leur désir de revanche sur l'ordre
patriarcal tout est comme sa déception
d'abord c'est ce qui vient de lire et
pat symonds scandaleux je suis désolé du
mans ce qu'on trouvait à la rigueur fait
réagir une salle sur ce land athènes
mais le pays ne va pas se lever en masse
oui avec c'est scandaleux avec son
million si l'union des raisons vers le
mont national effet si l'on prend les
réseaux
je ne vais pas le front national tous
ceux qui ont vu engueuler marine le pen
récemment où sauf que vous avez tort et
vous avez tort exprès mais j'ai le sac
était fait c'est celle des trains
express ça veut dire que vous êtes vous
arrivé avec une idée préconçue à la fois
de ce livre est son octobre je les lui
c'est ahurissant mais non je suis désolé
je les lui et que vous dites mais figure
pas et j'invite les gens à se faire une
opinion par eux mêmes mais en la jetant
ils ont aggravé les gens écouter les
gens quoi les gens pas si vous regardez
les regarder les quand je marche à toi
ma fille aux cruches derrière moi je
donne la parole mais regardez moi non
mais regardez moi quand je vous parle
moi je trouve moi moi vous me faites
peur ça vous des crimes comme scarface
vous font peur mais moi je trouve que
les libertés d'expression monsieur bio
mais c'est ma part il assure gars à
l'usiné elle est pour tout le monde
d'accord et brian de palma que vous
jugez comme comme un horrible personnage
a fait d'autres films sont pas forcément
tous comme scarface et lacinema monsieur
c'est la vie il faut montrer des choses
étaient claires mais je n'ai pas
beaucoup entendu dire à propos de ce
quart fait que c'était un film
dégueulasse parce qu'on en dise il coupe
un homme à la tronçonneuse tous vivants
on ne l'est jamais je tends le film est
sorti on a vu les gens qui voulaient
faire quoi voulez bien je vais faire ici
dans les débris des tragédies grecques
c'était pire les débats ou la levée des
débats c'est pas gagné dans les débats
des biens derrière de découvrir aux gens
qui commettent ce genre c'est bien sûr
je peux faire un truc ça ces derniers
mois moi j'ai pas le temps d'être
politain petit slip mon phare jura
hier j'ai pas le temps moi et c'est là
parce que là le ton va merci merci la
crise en combat sans merci en tous les
cas ce qu'il a jusqu'ici rares ça
s'appelle enfants sans foi ni loi et
c'est publié aux éditions du rocher
merci et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux